we're not we're can we cancel culture no
we're not cancer culture isn't it
it means it's real but it's not it's
it's only as
realistic let it be i mean you know
i i don't i don't really have any views
on it because i can't what do you think
about the cancellation of carlos mencia
well it's interesting is that i saw that
video and i i don't dislike carlos i
don't i
met him one time i've only met him once
and it was after a bunch of stuff
you know i think that it didn't it
didn't
seem to me personally that there was a
bunch of reflection done
i mean like in watching it it just
seemed and like i said
i should preface this i only saw it like
10 times no i'm kidding i only saw it
once i only watched it once
yeah and it just seemed like it see
like he he seemed to be saying two
things at the same time at times
where he was like i never did that but
i've already apologized to them for
doing that and i was at times and i was
like
i was like and that's where and i think
that's where i
land with bobby is that when you're
someone who over
shares you tell everyone everything
about everything you've done
you put your dirt on the table and then
you you you're accountable for that dirt
i've i've i've look i'll tell a tall
tale all day long to make you laugh
right
i'm gonna but that's the thing with tall
tales that's bobby's problem i'm like
look sweetie
you can over share yeah but the problem
with him is that he is an exaggerator
and
he embellishes everything yeah but
that's that's but he'll take what would
should have been
just a regular like benign story of
like being a young guy but then he will
just
put all the [ __ ] nasty bells and
whistles on there so now it's a
cancellable cancelable story and i'm
like you cannot be doing that yeah yeah
that's well
you can't do that but but i think that's
also
this is way sharing but i think that is
the people that he was around at the
time
yeah that is what they were celebrating
right was the
horrible bells and whistles i i don't i
try to i try not to surround myself
with people that are like and then i i i
put my dick in her mouth while she was
sleeping like that none of my friends
really thought that was like
by the way let me rephrase this i
actually i actually used one of my jokes
right then
i just used my so ignore whatever the
[ __ ] i say
that was a joke i used to have it's in
one of my specials
where is it special is that is that but
i it's so outrageous i wouldn't think
you'd really think i did that
i was saying i was trying to get a
[ __ ] from my wife i tried the
sensitive approach you know where you
slide in her mouth while she's sleeping
yeah she's like oh i'm like you're
snorkeling
you're sparkling in the keys you're
dreaming feel the fish bouncing off your
chin
look i don't know don't even [ __ ]
listen to me there's no reason to
[ __ ] listen to me
i'm [ __ ] skating on thin ice as it is
people i'm just trying to get the
[ __ ] 50 okay
leanne is a [ __ ] saint by the way yes
she is i when i
am just at my wit's end with bobby
i look to her for guidance i go on any
podcast leanne is on
and i listen to it like it's [ __ ]
it's it's my
it's my bible because i'm like i don't
know how to do this
this woman has it down to a science when
i saw the messiah thing and they just go
back to this
it didn't seem like his stories were
adding up and it just seemed like
that you're you're i was just watching
it going like
so did you did you're not like i do
think there's times like there was one
documentary we did where he was like
that's right i steal your material
and i do it better try to double down on
it and that was a mistake
yeah and i was like i was like don't do
that you don't do that like and that's
and because i i that wasn't the no one
in our
i was particularly frustrated that
episode because
i think it was a great you guys did a
great job i think i did
i was so i beat myself up after that
because i was like wait a second like
i i've met the man outside of here you
know i've met his family and
i see how he is and he is a sweet sweet
guy so i think that coming into it my
expectation was that he was just gonna
be like
you know what like it's been 14 years
like if i did it
[ __ ] what a mistake like i think i
really thought that
here's what there's a way out of this
there's a redemption story here here's
what we
here's what we wanted i'll tell you what
as a comic what i wanted to hear
and by the way there is a redemption
story out of this because
i don't i don't i'd never have disliked
carlos yeah i've i've
met him one time that's it yeah i
disliked his practice of business
i i personally didn't trust it to to be
in the room with it
if he i i think
i think it's hard to do i mean even in
saying here's what i think he should do
i think it's hard to do because he would
have had to say you know
let's talk about that ari joke for
example and he goes yeah i saw him do it
i saw him do it but i if he had said and
i'm not saying this is the right thing
i'm saying
this is what i didn't hear was i saw him
do that but i had already had the
thought a week before
and i had or i but i hadn't done it and
i didn't do it his way i did it my way
and you guys are going to understand a
lot of people like like if he tried to
talk about the actual
a couple bits that made sense one thing
he's done very well is
is and i don't think he did this on
purpose was talk about
how unkind he was to younger comics and
how he wanted to bury people
and how he wanted to but like i think
some of the stuff that
that joe has brought up and joe doesn't
talk about this at all
not to me personally i want to be very
clear i haven't i have not
talked to joe about carlos mancia
if someone's going to pull up a cliff
with me and joke those podcasts 15 times
you talk to him about it
but i'm saying like personally we don't
text back and forth about mancia i
didn't text him a clip of
did you see him on tiger belly like that
just didn't happen
but um i i think if the actual offenses
that people were bringing up
if he went down the line and said let's
talk about that
that people said i would do their closer
before they went on
to to bury them i think that was one of
the things but see you know how we were
talking about like empathy right and
really kind of putting yourself in
someone's shoes
what if 20 years from now we look back
we find out
that we were wrong about him that he
really
did not do it that we had somehow
our perception of whatever happened was
wrong and people piled on
and that you know he stuck to his guns
because
that was his truth well you know that's
interest that's an interesting take
and and i think adversely i don't i
would say i have not
judged him i've tried not to judge him
and i don't really have an experience
with him stealing from me
yeah once you steal from me then i can
really contextualize it and i've been
stolen from
four or five times and my thing right
now is to try to let go of those grudges
because i hold grudges i don't trust
people i don't trust
dudes like that's why i i i get hesitant
sometimes
you know to go to the store because
sometimes the wolves are out there and
you're like
you know even with joe being there like
being so prevalent there
you know look the premise is a promise
people you know
it takes a very very strong-willed comic
to watch someone do
something so close to being good
and not go i know the take on that and
then them do it for themselves i
consider that stealing
i don't know i i because there were bits
and pieces where i did
understand what he was saying um
but you know when i when we were done
with all of that i just felt really sad
it was it was a tough interview to watch
because i i wanted
i wanted to you know i wanted more
i mean i think you know and look i i
like i said i only watched it once but
like i thought you guys did a really
good job of kind of
holding him to what you believe the
truth to be yeah but i also had this i
like in my head i'm like this is gonna
be a hard reset
all those premises that he stole 14
years ago are no longer being told on
stage
anyways so here here's our [ __ ] hard
reset the guy is sorry
let's move on but it just kind of didn't
turn out that way you know what you know
what
you know what bob or what is not really
it's hard to understand for a lot of
people a lot of especially a lot of
podcast fans now is
just how much no one liked each other
back then yeah so that's
i don't know if that's a hard thing for
them to understand i think they they
know that because like
it all the stories that i hear about
back then it just seemed like the wild
wild west there are no rules everyone
was just beating the [ __ ] out of each
other trying to just
you know bump each other as like bobby
would say like
who was it like eddie griffin would stay
on for three [ __ ] hours
i remember hearing stories of like
people getting double spots which
doesn't happen now
but also the shift in podcasting changed
it so that i could benefit
from bobby in a way that i couldn't
before
like i could benefit from and joe could
benefit from
me in a way that it would never have joe
rogan could never have
benefited from befriending me or being
nice to me
i mean he was just that guy because
that's who he was yeah but then when
it's podcasting start up
and then you go i come on and i tell a
story and all the fans are like that's a
great story have one again and joe has
me on again i tell another good story
and then i'm
wild and i get drunk and i'm on travel
channel i'm telling these crazy stories
about jumping off buildings and